in the latest evidence the media have
lost their minds over the election of
President Trump outlets all over the
country went nuts over Trump senior
adviser Kellyanne Conway putting her
feet on a couch in the Oval Office while
taking a photo of Trump with top
officers and historically black colleges
is what the picture looked like here's
buzzfeed's deputy news director shoes on
the couch in the Oval Office here a
certified nut job Keith Olbermann get
your effing feet off the furniture
Kellyanne pulse this isn't your home
here is a digital organizer for Hillary
Clinton Conway with her shoes on the
couch and Oval Office consistent with
general level of disrespect Trump team
has shown here are some of the headlines
USA Today Kellyanne Conway puts feet on
oval office couch Twitter freaks New
York Daily News Kellyanne Conway
photograph making herself comfortable on
oval office couch protocols how Trump
advisor for disrespect us weekly
Kellyanne Conway meals on oval office
couch Twitter freaks out New York Post
Kellyanne Conway Nielsen oval off sparks
debate the telegraph from the UK show
some class Kellyanne Conway accused of
lacking respect after putting feet up on
oval office couch oh no the horror
Kellyanne Conway put her feet on the
couch like a human even the Washington
Post Chris chilis I got this one right
he said quote this tempest in a teapot
is in a word dumb into words incredibly
dumb of course chalisa then goes on to
get one thing wrong he equates Conway's
conduct with data President Clinton in
the Oval Office which neglects a few
facts first Kellyanne Conway is not the
president second bill clinton's intern
performed oral sex on him in the Oval
Office Kellyanne Conway kneeling on a
couch isn't quite the same thing as
Monica Lewinsky kneeling under the desk
or having sex on top of the oval office
desk with Clinton as secret service
members reported as for the generalized
the outrage or her feet on the furniture
in the Oval Office President Obama
routinely put his death at his feet on
the resolute desk a gift from Queen
Victoria Victoria to president
rutherford b hayes in 1890 let so did
george w bush and gerald ford in other
words everybody needs to calm down it's
the biggest problem the media have with
Kellyanne Conway is where she puts her
feet in the Oval Office they are just
awful at their jobs I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
so lots coming up we're going to talk
about Donald Trump's address to Congress
that's happening tonight he's proposed
his new budget will go through that and
talk about what's good and what's bad
and it will also talk about whether the
Democrats are smart to hitch their
entire political future to bashing
Donald Trump whether that's a winning
strategy or a losing strategy their
arguments both ways but first we have to
say thank you to our friends over a
different recruiters it recruiters one
of our advertisers if you are an
employer and you are looking to get the
best applicants for a job you need to go
to ziprecruiter com there you can post
your drops of 200 plus job sites
including social media networks like
Facebook and Twitter with a single click
so instead of having to go to a ton of
sites and then post your job there you
can go instead to ziprecruiter it'll do
all of it for you can find candidates in
any city in any industry nationwide just
post lunch and you watch those qualified
candidates roll into your zip recruiter
easy-to-use interface you can dismiss
resumes you don't like you can accept
the ones you do you don't have to juggle
emails or calls to your office you
screen the candidates you rate them and
hire the right person fast using
ziprecruiter com it's been used by
Fortune 100 companies there's a reason
for that right now my listeners can you
zip recruiter to post jobs for free you
go to ziprecruiter calm / daily wire
ziprecruiter calm / daily wire at
ziprecruiter calm / daily wire it is a
great service is something that we've
started to use we're going to start
using over here at daily wire and I
recommend that you use it for your
business to is cheap it is easy right
now if you use ziprecruiter calm and you
put in daily wire you get it for free
and you can try it for free and see how
it works for you again post your job do
200 plus sites including Facebook and
Twitter with a single click of a button
save yourself tons of time and it's an
easy-to-use interface so make sure that
you can get the employees that you need
okay so we begin today with the media
the media obviously are overreaching
right now and the biggest advantage that
Donald Trump has in the political debate
is clearly the insanity of the media
because he goes out there any bashes the
media and everybody who is on the right
side of the aisle implicitly loves this
we all love this because the media have
it coming for 20 years swansea long in
30 years I mean going all the way back
to Ronald Reagan going back to Nixon the
media have been far to the left and they
have unfairly targeted Republicans like
some targeting as fair sum is not but
the fact that Trump is striking back in
the media it works well for him it works
particularly well for him when the media
continue to overreach and make
themselves look insane the left and the
media have decided the only way the left
is going to regain power is simply by
attacking Trump attacking Trump
attacking Trump now I think what's in
their mind they think that they're going
to do to trump what they did to george w
bush they think that if they can just
polarize Bush enough to get Nancy Pelosi
and Obama in they can polarize Trump
enough to get Cory Booker or Elizabeth
Warren in in four years but this is
neglect a couple of facts first George W
Bush actually had to do some pretty bad
things as president in order to lose his
approval rating and watch it plummet
presidents who have over a forty percent
approval rating have a legit shot at
re-election if you're below forty
percent basically you're toast Trump
right now is anywhere from 40 42 fifty
percent and according Rasmussen a little
bit about fifty percent in terms of
approval rating if he's six in that
range he'll have a legit shot at
reelection and in order for a
president's really drop below that range
has to do something really bad and
usually that means some sort of economic
recession or a war that is prosecuted
poorly george HW bush george HW bush was
riding really high who's in like the 80s
after the gulf war and then there was an
economic recession and plummeted down
into the 30s george w was in the 50s for
the vast majority of his first term
after nine eleven news in the 90s after
the Iraq war his in the 60s he basically
spent most of his first from hovering
around fifty five fifty six percent and
then it was only after his re-election
when the Iraq war really started to go
south before the surge that his approval
ratings dumped in tank for the last time
then there was a recession so he had the
double whammy and he ended up in the 20s
right now Trump isn't involved in any
long-standing war you know Afghanistan
is still going on but that's really not
considered his war he hasn't started a
war that's going badly and the economy
is doing pretty well so long as those
two things hold true attacking Trump
isn't going to do a lot for the media
but that's not stopping them they think
that if they just attack trump attacked
Trump that will alleviate their
responsibilities not suck at their jobs
and if the left keeps attacking Trump
they won't have to run Democrats who
aren't insane so this is what you see
from the media so Mika Brzezinski over
at MSNBC she says the Trump is clearly
trying to create a dictatorship again
over the top spies are defended the
decision to limit the press
I think that we have shown in abundance
of accessibility we brought more
reporters into this process and the idea
that every time that every single person
can get their question answer to fit in
a room or excluding people we've
actually gone above and beyond with
making ourselves our team and our
briefing room more accessible than
probably any prior administration so I
think you can take that to the bank so
there's a different spicer that we have
for you back in December here he is we
have a respect for the press when it
comes to the government that that is
something that you can't ban an entity
from you know conservative liberal or
otherwise I think that's what makes a
democracy a democracy versus a
dictatorship
just let that marinate yeah I mean so is
that where we're at anybody want to
participate I mean I is he just
described himself 70 days maybe a long
time at his minor seven days ago so we
are they trying to create a dictatorship
i mean i i'm not i'm not joking and I'm
not angry okay I'm not joking around
angry are they trying to create a
dictatorship if they are this is the
worst dictatorship ever okay honestly
like I think people are right to be
afraid of authoritarian so far everybody
seems pretty able to criticize him and
dictatorship usually don't have any
cobras MC on there talking about how the
dictatorship is being created as a
typical matter and Brzezinski hasn't
been banned from the air but again the
media have to overreach because they
think that if they destroyed Trump then
they are going to destroy the Republican
Party what they figure is that the
Republican Party's seen a major upswing
since 2010 thanks in large parts of
Barack Obama their dominant across the
country in localities and states their
dominance in the federal government but
now they've tethered their wagons Donald
Trump's if they burn Donald Trump down
the wagon will burn too so they're going
to focus all their fire on Donald Trump
chris matthews doing the same thing he
says I don't understand why would it why
would anybody believe Trump have to use
if chris matthews be safe get up come
here they show come in here a wrinkle
don't even know what I'm doing and then
I just talk I say things and people
watch it sometimes but at MSNBC says not
too many people Kathleen what do you
think go nooses earlier evening news
analysis and opinion he doesn't go after
lefties he doesn't have to Center
lefties he goes after people producing
news on the front page hard-working
enterprise reporting that's always going
after have you noticed that's certainly
the case here but you know do you
explain it is sort of an element here he
took it again looking for an enemy this
is somebody who spent his entire career
in negotiations we can't have a
negotiation with one party I mean you
can't have a super hero without a
villain there's an element of like why
would anybody believe Trump would come
spend years saying that Barack Obama was
an illegal alien its importance belief
why would they believe when they know he
was wrong about the big thing he ran on
for five years why would they believe
he's got some new truth coming out of
them well the irony is that he has set
up a hit obama's so much they love to
have them you know trash by singing
that's right it's not
it's confirmation bias and people
believe what they want to believe get
confirmation bias are you listening
lefties who are watching Chris Matthews
of our numbers embassy it's confirmation
bias they understand that's right you
have a bias nobody confirms the bike if
I stay here a nice day it's Donald Trump
is the worst thing that ever was and
people think it's news maybe it's
because they already got is the worst
thing that ever was that's confirmation
mice but doesn't apply to make them on
the left also I come out of the show and
I was like to eat soup the restrainer I
don't know why infinity case then the
media has decided they don't understand
why it is that Trump has any credibility
after all of this has happened here's
the funny thing there's a poll yesterday
from Wall Street Journal NBC News and
what it found is that fifty two percent
of americans think the media have gone
overboard on Trump because they have
again that Kellyanne Conway photo is a
great example of this the fact that the
media have lost their mind over this
photo of Kellyanne Conway with her feet
on the couch it's just absurd it's just
absurd and it demonstrates how far
they're willing to go there is a
strategy to it again the strategy is if
you can polarize about Trump maybe take
down the entire Republican Party because
you figure the Trump is the figurehead
for the Republican Party he's a really
volatile figurehead and maybe you can
maybe he's the anchor that drags down
the Republicans it's not just the media
obviously it's also Democrats so Nancy
Pelosi is out there to the Botox lady
the Botox is now seeped into her
neurological structures and she says
that it's time to impeach trumpets 40
days and times impeach from what the
administration was making a strong case
with the American people and perhaps
misrepresenting American people could
because her impeachment if so there's
plenty of grounds right now with the
current president but it just does
indicate that doesn't mean nobody's
listening to cases that are being made
in a very scientific methodical way as
to whether there are grounds for
impeachment but the fact is is that many
of China unite the country and many of
the president's supporters are just not
ready to accept the fact that that their
judgment might not been it so great and
voting for him and by the time the case
is made perhaps they'll be ready to
accept that yes clearly Democrats are
ready to unite the country
around impeaching trumpet this is the
same thing look Nancy Pelosi only has
one speed and that speed is impeach Bush
impeach Trump wouldn't matter to Ben
Rubio could've in romney would have been
exactly the same case made by the
democrats maxine waters another one of
these radical Democrats from California
she says the Trump obviously colluded
with Russia to steal the election by the
way is the same lady who said the LA
riots for the LA uprisings when people
were burning down storefronts owned by
koreans in south central los angeles i
was in uprising courting maxine waters
she also says that Trump colluded with
Russia here to say that my colleagues
and the leadership would not like to
hear me say that I word but I'd say it
over and over again impeachment
impeachment of a president absolutely
was in collusion with the Kremlin and
Putin in Russia during the campaign I
believe that and I believe that they
undermined our democracy by interfering
with our election and I think that meets
the criteria for impeachment in addition
to that the storage that I'm trying to
get out is the connection of all of
those around him with Russia and with
the Kremlin and the fact that they're
going for the oil that's why you hear a
lot about listen the sanctions they're
going for the oil what is she even
talking about it shouldn't same yes
she's an insane person actually the
answer is yes she is a crazy person
going for the oil oil prices are the
lowest they've been in 20 years what is
she saying going for the oil and
whatever Maxine Waters appears on the
show like this i'm just waiting for
jerry springer to pop out in birthday
we're going to take a paternity test
here on this particular show of masking
waters in any case the democrats have
decided that that Donald Trump is is
impeachable and again this is part of a
broader strategy now Chuck Schumer has a
bit of a different strategy and I'll get
to chuck schumer strategy and a little
bit but first we have to say thank you
to our advertisers over at Birch gold so
if you are somebody who's looking at the
economy and figuring to yourself well
things are really good but maybe they'll
go south maybe I ought to diversify if
you're somebody who is looking at the at
the global financial markets and saying
that
seemed to be a tremendous amount of
stability here yeah I have a little bit
your money in precious metals and if you
want to put some of your money and
precious metals you need to talk to my
friends over at Birch gold group 8 plus
rating from the better business bureau a
lot of five-star ratings and if you
contact them now to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals you can do so at Birch gold look
calm / Benton Birch gold calm / been and
they can teach you how to move your 401k
or your IRA out of stocks and bonds and
into precious metals the material that
has never been worth zero a great hedge
against inflation a great hedge against
economic collapse to get that no cost no
obligation kit again go to Birch gold
calm / been ask all your questions and
get all your answers and then when
you're ready to invest in precious
metals talk to my friends over at Birch
gold calm / bed now here's the thing the
Democrats are turning Trump into the
enemy and this has been their strategy
not just with Trump or with Bush but
it's been going back for really the
entirety of the time pretty much the
entire 20th century the Democrats have
made this case the case they've made is
that Democrats are fighting the enemy
and the enemy are these these evil
Republicans who want to stand in the way
of progress and their racist sexist
bigot homophobe and they're people who
don't they don't agree with the with the
greatness of American government and
their John lips goin footloose and they
want to stop Kevin Bacon from dancing
and all the rest of it it has always
been the pitch Republicans are the enemy
and Republicans for most of the 20th
century made the case as a real enemy
where the Soviet right the Communists
the International communist swarthy were
the greatest threat to American security
and most of the time Americans looked at
the Soviet Union and they said right
that's a bigger threat than the
Republicans and that's why you end up
with President Eisenhower and President
Nixon and President Reagan because
Americans generally believed the
Republicans when they said your enemy is
the Russians your enemy is a Soviet they
didn't believe Democrats as much when
the Democrats said your enemy is the
Republicans then the Soviet Union Falls
and basically Republicans don't win
presidential elections right they win 12
popular presidential election since the
one since the fall of the Soviet Union
in the popular vote they've won one
popular presidential election in 2004
and that was a real act right because
Bush lost the popular vote in two
thousand and Trump lost the popular vote
in 2016 basically the case the Democrats
have made is still the same case
Republicans are the enemies of the
American people and Republicans have
sort of picked a variety of enemies it's
been you know
it's been the radical Muslims or it's
been the Chinese or it's been the
Russians in the case of Mitt Romney they
pick enemies and the American people go
well are they really so scary are they
really so scary so the only time that
works was in 2004 when the answer was
yes they really are that scary radical
Islamic terrorism could actually kill
Americans it does the only time that
worked a lot of elections take place
under the rubric of who's enemies do you
most want to fight whose enemies you
most want to fight so you also want to
fight Republicans or you most want to
fight the Russians or the Chinese now
the thing about Trump right now is that
the Democrats are saying that the great
enemy is from Trump is the enemy the
same case they've always made it's the
Republicans and Trump they're the enemy
Donald Trump has another series of
enemies and those enemies are pretty
popular people don't like those enemies
very much so Donald Trump for example he
really hates the press it turns out
American really don't like the press
attacking the press is a good enemy for
Donald Trump Donald Trump has his own
set of enemies in there pretty good so
here's Donald Trump saying yesterday he
doesn't want to do the white house
correspondents dinner because hey the
media is terrible a lot of the stories
are made up I believe a lot of the
stories of pure fiction they just pull
it out of there now with all of that
being said I just thought it would be
better if I didn't do the dinner that
doesn't mean I'm not going to do that
this year but I just thought it would be
better if I sure didn't do this okay so
the media are his enemies the media are
you know in the public view the media
are not our friends right there also are
enemies in many ways and this is why the
media publicity route that they're
they're sort of approval ratings are
very well actually much lower than
president Trump Donald Trump says your
enemies of the democrats democrats
approval ratings right now are far below
those of President Trump Trump says
Barack Obama is the enemy Americans
approval rating for Obamacare is really
not very good here's Donald Trump saying
that Obama is behind the recent protest
against a lot of things he's trying to
do we talked about President Obama he
said you personally get along with them
you guys are going at each other for
three or four maybe eight years it turns
out his organization it seems to be
doing a lot of the organizing so some of
the protests and a lot of these
Republicans are seeing around the
country and against you do you believe
President Obama's behind it and if he is
is that a violation of the book also
called unsaid
code no I think he is behind it I also
think it's politics that's the way it is
and look I have a vote was never the
bush wasn't going after Clinton Clinton
was going after a bush but you never
know what's exactly happening behind the
scenes you know you're probably right or
possibly right but you never know no I
think that President Obama is behind it
because it's people certainly behind it
and some of the leaks possibly come from
that group you know some of the leaks
which are really very seriously because
they're very bad internalized national
security to write the enemy of Obama is
still out there hehe yesterday he blamed
Hollywood leftism for their floods at
the Oscars he said you know you were
wasting so much time bashing me you
forgot to actually hand out the right
does below at the Oscars bashing
Hollywood will actually they're they're
a good enemy there an enemy that most
Americans don't like he doesn't like
China right is like Mexico right these
are these are enemies that most
Americans are pretty much okay with
Americans are okay with Mexico actually
American I think we have a sixty-two
percent approval rating of Mexico but on
China Americans aren't real fond of
China in other words Trump has his own
series of enemies and by attacking those
enemies he makes himself more popular if
Democrats keep attacking Trump there's
no guarantee that makes them more
popular or that it makes Trump any less
popular because Trump is a known
quantity the electorate is already so
polarized in an area where the
electrodes not polarized attacking Bush
works when Bush had a forty percent
approval rating from Democrats going in
and that goes down to zero but what
happens when Trump's at forty-five
percent and his approval rating among
Democrats is three there's no room to
move there's no actually move that crowd
so I'm not sure that the actual about
strategy for Democrats is attacking
Trump as easy a target as he seems to be
and that's one of the secret strengths
of Donald Trump meanwhile the paranoid
style of politics that Trump engages in
sort of everybody is my enemy routine
there's something to that in that if
everybody is your enemy there's very
likely to be crossover with the American
public on their enemies if you have lots
of enemies good shot that you and Donald
Trump have some enemies in common
whether you're on the right or the left
if you're on the left then you also
believe that the globalists right the
globalist are in charge of the world
economy cinemates some of your enemies
are Donald Trump's enemies if you're on
the right Donald Trump attacking the
bureaucracy the bureaucracy is your
enemy so Donald Trump by having tons of
enemies it looks like a paranoid style
of politics but it's actually kind of
smart so talk more about that I also
want to talk about Donald Trump on
policy because
we're going to get his joint address to
Congress tonight but for that you're
gonna have to go to the daily wire calm
and subscribe daily wire calm eight
bucks a month will ensure that you are
able to see the rest of this show you
can be part of the mailbag on Thursdays
you're also going to get the Shapiro
store I promise is opening soon so we'll
be getting that out we're also giving
away free copies of the arroyo the
fictional movie about what's going on on
our southern border rancher taking on
the drug cartels who are smuggling is
illegal immigrants across american land
and get that for free over at daily wire
calm when you become an annual
subscriber so eight bucks a month or
become an annual subscriber if you just
want to listen to the rest of the show
later then go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and you can check it out
later we are the number one conservative
podcast in America
[Music]